Unidentified: So it's been
Speaker 1: months since I did
our last sort of comprehensive COVID
update about where we are and sadly,
the reason I'm doing such a segment today is
that many signs don't look good and there's
every indication that another spike
could be coming. Now there's still
the possibility that that's not the case, and
I'll talk about what that looks like in a moment.
But we will get to that. There is an argument
to be made that in general, cases are no longer
really the best indicator of the status of
the pandemic, that we should be looking at
hospitalizations and deaths, et cetera. And I
think that there's something to that. But still,
cases are a leading indicator of hospitalization
and death. The question is just to what degree?
Now none of us want another spike, but
unfortunately it does appear as though one
is coming and there is evidence from other
countries suggesting this. And unfortunately,
there's also evidence from the United States.
And as always, I am always going to report to you
the way things are, not the way I wish things
would be. So first and foremost, if we look at
global cases, what has been a massive decline from
nearly four million cases a day down well under
two million cases a day has reversed. Now this
is global so that we got down to a lower point
and global cases are now starting to go up. Now
they're not going up in the United States yet,
although I will argue that they actually are
and were. If you look at the right data that
you can see that. But where are we seeing
actual recorded case numbers increase? Well,
first and foremost, Germany, and they're not
only going up a little bit. Two days ago,
Germany had the most new cases in a single
day of the entire pandemic. It's exhausting.
I know it's exhausting, but about 300000 cases in
a single day in Germany, a pandemic record. You
look at Finland, Finland since about mid-January
has individually seen some higher case days. And
if you look now at the seven day rolling average
of new cases in Finland, it is at a pandemic high.
If you look at the United Kingdom massive
decline, remember at the peak of Akron,
the U.K. was seeing about 200000 known
cases per day, about two to 10 to 20.
That got all the way down below 50 50k and now
has gone back up by by about double. I mean, it's
where the U.K. has almost now doubled daily cases
from that bottoming out we saw at the beginning of
March. That's really not good because so far in
the pandemic, everything that's happened in the
U.K. has happened in the U.S. a little bit
later. And then you look at Iceland, Iceland,
which I mean, the entire pandemic looks
like almost nothing compared to the current
2500 cases a day that Iceland is seeing,
essentially at a pandemic high seven day average.
And lastly, if you look at Oh, I actually I
actually forget where this is, it doesn't say,
I believe that this is. Where is this, this
is somewhere in Asia. I was trying to give a
perspective globally, I did not even include
what country that says a new high. I think, wow,
I don't remember where that is. We'll get that
information. So, OK, cases are going up elsewhere,
but they're not going up in the U.S., right?
Well, not exactly in the United States,
as I've told you before. Wastewater COVID readings
can be a leading indicator even earlier than cases
about the direction that things are going. And
although Dr. Vincent Racaniello, not last time
he was on with us, said the wastewater data is
not an exact science. It is still a generally
speaking leading indicator. And there's an article
in Bloomberg. U.S. sewer data warns of a new bump
in COVID cases after lull data from wastewater
can spot a rise in infections before it shows
up in positive tests. And unfortunately, it's not
looking good. More than a third of the Siddiqui's
wastewater sample sites across the U.S. show
rising COVID trends from March one to March 10,
even though cases remain at a record low. The
number of sites with rising signals of COVID
is nearly twice what it was during the Feb. one to
10 period. It's not clear how many new infections
the signs in the sewage represent, and if they
will turn into a new wave, or will it be just
a brief bump on the way down from the last one?
So obviously we all hope that this is going to
be maybe a leveling out in the United States and
then we continue down or maybe a slight uptick.
The unfortunate thing is if we're totally honest
and transparent, if you look at what's starting
to happen in other countries, it doesn't bode
particularly well. Now everything's wide open,
even though you still have people protesting
mandates and closures in the United States,
there essentially are none. Everything's open,
everything's happening. And quite frankly, I
don't know what should be taking place right now.
I. There is such I mean, it's been more than two
years now of this almost to the day. It's been two
years and a week or something like that of this at
this point in time. The political will to continue
having things shut down is almost completely gone.
The social motivation to do it is almost
completely gone. The infection fatality rate is
significantly lower. That doesn't mean that if
things get completely out of control in cases,
people aren't going to die. They are, and I am
not in a position where I am going to say close
everything it. We now know that close
everything is too broad a strategy, and
we know that close everything in many cases didn't
even really achieve what we wanted it to achieve
but do. Nothing also doesn't make sense if we see
another spike, so we're going to be following the
data. We're going to be tracking what happens,
particularly the UK. Numbers are not looking good,
and so far we everything that happens in
the UK happens here four to six weeks later.
So my expectation is that by April 1st, we are
going to see higher cases in the US than we see
right now. Why do I think that? Because it's
already in the wastewater data, it's up. It's
already there. There's no way it would be any
other way. The question is, is it just a little
bump plateau? And then we continue down or
not? And I don't know the answer to that.